this video is sponsored by Squarespace
for the last 5 years I've made it my
mission to try and train like Batman not
for any noble cause or good reason of
course not because I'm trying to save
Gotham City just because it's fun and
it's fascinating and because I don't
like to pigeon hole my performance well
it's been longer than that really but
it's been about 5 years since I began
consistently training with the same and
documenting the experiment here on
YouTube of course it's not really been
about B man I tell people I'm training
like Batman because that's the easiest
way to communicate what I'm really
trying to do I want to train to be
faster stronger more agile to have
greater Mobility cardio and cognitive
performance is to improve every aspect
of my physical and mental performance
through
training and along the way I've been
fortunate to experiment with some really
cool stuff I've trained alongside some
incredible athletes and I've spoken with
some of the biggest names in functional
training
here is what I've
learned first performance is not a
priority for most people these are my
goals for training but they're actually
pretty out there most training programs
seem to be designed to improve
Aesthetics that might mean improving
muscle mass or losing weight some people
are interested in getting a little
healthier maybe or rehabbing injuries
but that's about as far as the more
functional minded routines go with the
exception of course of training routines
designed around building strength or
developing specific athletic ability you
know people who do powerlifting as a
hobby or functional training for a
specific sport but in these cases
they're often pushing themselves really
far in One Direction but creating
deficits in other areas so you have
powerlifters for example who might be
interested in building massive strength
but who have no concern for cardio or
Mobility then you get Runners who can
run huge dist distances but have no real
upper body
strength and often functional training
aimed specifically at athletes can
actually be detrimental to health over
time this is why I coined the term super
functional
training
secondly I learned where my limitations
are real life gets in the way of
training like Batman who'd have thought
he's a recluse for a reason there are
only so many hours in the day especially
if you're a parent injuries will happen
even to the most careful recovery is
arguably the most important piece of the
puzzle and that means taking a slow and
methodical approach it means only
choosing the most useful exercises and
strategies and leaving out what's not
necessary and along the way I've
discovered some things that are far more
potent than others I'm going to recap
them a little bit here for
you so early on I discovered the value
of big drop sets and pump training to
grow muscles faster and to increase
blood flow via angiogenesis I think this
kind of pump training gets a bad wrap
due to its association with pure
Aesthetics but actually it has a lot
going for it and I'd later learn that
the atg truth group does something
similar with their short range training
after researching Bruce Lee I began
using overcoming isometrics to
accelerate strength gains that's pushing
or pulling against an immovable force
and lately I've been experimenting with
using overcoming isometrics on
Resistance machines at the point of
failure and this experiment is currently
showing a lot of Promise feels very
Batman as well to be experimenting with
these kind of techniques to build
strength of course the basic lifts and
things like the deadlift are really
important and they're the basics for for
a reason they provide a really good
foundation but we mustn't Overlook other
aspects of strength such as rotational
strength and grip strength which can
make just as big a
difference I've also been experimenting
with extremely slow quasi isometric
movements for the last several years and
that can have transformative effects on
your body
control so that's a great place to start
but I also learned that for most people
Mobility limitations are more pressing
than strength deficits lower body
Mobility is severely hampered for most
people to the point that they can barely
use their hips I still have a long way
to go before I gain the freedom of
movement that I want in this area slow
movements and undulations at stretched
positions have helped a great deal with
this as has weightage
[Music]
stretching training outdoors and using
tree branches and logs genuinely builds
more adaptable strength and grip power
in much the same way this kind of
training is to strengthen training what
sparring is to martial arts is about
taking a practice and pressure testing
it something that I think many more
people can benefit from I've talked at
length about the ideas of Nikolai
Bernstein and repetition without
repetition and I highly recommend
looking into
that and using barefoot shoes on a
similar note has genuinely been
revelatory for the increased proception
control and balance I wouldn't go
back scheduled deep thinking has done
more to improve my mindset and
creativity than any other brain training
strategy I did this intuitively but I
later discovered it was a form of
non-directive meditation and I've coined
the term big idea meditation for
this through the channel I met
functional training luminary JC Santana
who explained to me the importance of
training ankle stiffness for
explosiveness and showed me how this was
more important than heavy squats for
things like running and jumping after
all when does a basketball player ever
stop and do a deep squat in order to
dunk in reality the leg hardly bends
beyond the running position as they
launch off of one foot it's about
transferring power not generating it
this just serves to highlight that Real
Performance is often not what you
expect JC also explained the importance
of psychomotor vigilance keeping the
Mind sharp even when you're tired a
perfect example of brain training that
genuinely applies to real world
performance strength endurance in
general is also really important it's
not about being able to do something
strong wants it's about being able to
exert strength and performance for an
extended period of time under pressure
and to that end learning about military
training I discovered many times just
how important this aspect is for those
top performers psychology here is
perhaps the number one thing that keeps
you alive in a crisis but training this
is not for the faint-hearted holding
static poses and subjecting yourself to
grueling mental challenges facing your
fears this teaches you to control your
thoughts and nervous system this is to
go beyond the scope of most of the
training I cover on this channel it's
something that I'm interested in
discussing but whether or not it's
something many of us need I don't know
it's certainly very Batman if you
genuinely want to take your skills and
make them more
applicable neurot trainer meanwhile
makers of some brain training software
explain to me the role of working memory
in sports Vision something you can
develop with juggling and software and
this also plays a key role in skill
acquisition and is an important part of
training Elite performers
most valuable of all for me though has
been the process of learning new skills
I started a long journey to developed my
hand balancing which developed my
balance my core my mobility and my
understanding of the body learning
Concepts like straight arm strength and
scapular control teaches you a language
of movement that can then be applied to
countless other forms of training you
can learn other new skills more
quickly Grant helped me to develop my
punching technique this in turn helped
me to generate power from my core and to
move the body more like a
whip Liam later helped me improve my
parkour role and showed me the proper
way to climb up I've been practicing all
these things on my own ever since so
many aspects of movement that are
usually overlooked getting help on my
kettle bell swing improved my
explosiveness but also fixed my hip
hinge and moves like this are skills in
themselves I'm currently working on my
running form with help from the online
community I would strongly recommend
everyone to continually add to their
movement vocabulary like this and anyone
who wants to perform like Batman should
learn to punch roll climb and balance
again it's balancing all of this which
is the challenge but the key is to
understand which aspects are crucial and
which are
optional this is the difference between
comic books and real life we can't
simply apply a batman-like mindset to
real life and expect not to get injured
unlike Batman we can't be the strongest
and the fastest but the logical choice
for allaround performance is to
sacrifice some strength for Speed and
vice
versa this means making peace with
slower gains at times but then I
personally can't understand the mindset
of someone who will work tirelessly to
add 5 kg to their bench press while
being unable to climb the stairs without
getting
winded this selective use of our time
extends to what we do beyond our
training too beware the activities that
promise a lot but amount to little more
than spinning our Wheels as the bioneer
I've experimented with countless
supplements neurot Tropics fitness
trackers bioh hacks and devices that
border on transhumanism some of these
have been effective most have been
fascinating but a lot of them have been
dead ends and a waste of time a lot of
bioh hacks amount through overinflated
expectations and a waste of
money even if taking certain supplements
and sitting in ice baths will increase
your results by 5% that's not worth the
energy it takes to implement them save
that energy for the training don't
roleplay high performance just train and
For Heaven's Sake remember to have some
life outside of your training this isn't
just healthy it's actually crucial for
your progress don't be a gym cell don't
burn out keep learning and exploring
read books by Tom Myers Paul Czech pavl
satlin Nikolai Bernstein J Santana
Stuart MC Ben Patrick Bret contas
understanding the fascia and studying
the brain has helped me in countless
ways to train smarter and more
effectively it's not just about what you
do in the gym it's about continually
learning about your own body but again
implement the concepts through training
not through hacks we need to be
extremely mindful about what we are
training and
why and to help me with all this I
devised the atnp hierarchy a tool that I
use to identify the traits and
attributes that different activities
develop these are more important than
the activities themselves when it comes
to building a robust performance profile
and through injury time off or
circumstance I may lose individual moves
just as my bench press isn't as big now
as it was at the start of this process
but I won't lose the pro reception as
quickly or the knowledge and I'll regain
it much more quickly I've collected
these ideas and codified this training
in my online ebook and training program
superfunctional training 2.0 if you'd
like to try it for yourself you can find
a link in the description down below and
it's on discount for January it comes
with over 2 hours of instructional video
and an 80 plus page eBook The Journey is
never ending I will never be done and so
the biggest lesson from all of this the
body is the true final
frontier I hope you enjoyed that little
monologue guys I kind of thought it
would be interesting to make a sort of
recap of everything I've learned over
the years on the channel and to
highlight some of the things that
actually worked and stood out for me and
maybe a little bit of what didn't my
approach to training and my general
philosophy has definitely evolved a
great deal as a result of running this
Channel and it's through the searching
this Channel and testing the ideas and
getting feedback from you guys that my
own performance has grown far more than
I think it otherwise would have done I
also thought it might be nice to make a
kind of Montage of some of the
videography from Grant and Liam and some
of the more interesting days out just to
kind of summarize everything we've been
doing here this is not the Batman
training program for 2023 as I said in
Community post recently I'm actually
saving that for a million subscribers if
we hit a million subscribers my promise
to you guys is that we'll release the
next Batman training program hopefully
in the meantime this is something of a
compromise and I did also say that I'm
going to be working on a red hood
training program either way guys thank
you so much for watching this video
thank you for sticking around with me
for all these years a massive thank you
to everyone who's bought a training
program or supported me on patreon and
here's to making 2024 the best year yet
So yeah thank you so much guys and bye
for
now this video was sponsored by
Squarespace Squarespace is a website
building platform that makes it
extremely easy for anyone to get up and
running with their own website whilst
also offering all of the tools and
features you could need to build a
massive business getting started
couldn't be simpler you just choose a
template drag and drop elements to
customize it how you want you can be
live in under an hour genuinely and from
there you can start adding and using all
the different features available you've
got Advanced formatting tools for
creating beautiful blog posts and
Publishing them or scheduling them for
later you've got a fully integrated
commenting system with threaded comments
replies and likes member management
analytics gated members only content for
easy Revenue generation and then of
course there's comprehensive e-commerce
support so you can start selling
products directly from your site and
making a living that way and if you want
to take the capabilities of your website
even further then you can use the
countless plugins from the community and
from Squarespace themselves to add all
sorts of things like global tracking
Inventory management tax reconciliation
and so much more this is why some of the
biggest brands on the web use
Squarespace to power their online
presence if you want to learn more then
go to squarespace.com when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com
bioner and you can get 10% off of your
first domain or website thanks again to
Squarespace for sponsoring this video
thanks to you guys for watching and bye
for now